welcome to this video I'm playing buell
tech from Russia plate be 64 for a
change not quite sure if this is it this
is a good opening here but let's let's
just play something something different
okay so I need to attack the center
probably with e6 and then then maybe c5
only one that I should do it now or the
later stage c 5 fee well no actually on
c4 I can take a three and play 96 this
is a very nice position even so on yeah
this is not bad at all the bishop on d5
four folds are useful rollin oh I can't
take here and then take take e 5 if he
takes with the Queen winning a porn and
the process and G takes I mean looks
really ugly I can just take c5 then so
he decided to rather sacrifice um the
pawn
okay so it says something better than
taking yeah probably not check then grab
the spawn
yeah it's just a pond for pretty much
nothing oh hmm I didn't expect that I
thought maybe would go before at some
point try to get rid of the bishop that
now with the bishop is actually nicely
placed on c5 and turn my queen of six
most like that and so should I play
Queen hi can I can go here maybe set up
little trap Queen d7 look 28 and if the
Queen moves Queen have to look after
group d 1 made ok so i think is right on
the way to allow that Queen have to
check i dropped you one red
yeah nice little trick speeding up the
neat the wind enormously all right this
was very quick okay so let's have a
brief look at this at this opening
position I thought this was rather nice
now with the the oops no let's just take
the smooth like now this is a really
nice bishop and I have some some
pressure on the center really this Sam
is just leading to a to clear black
advantage simply with the pawn but yeah
I can also go d 5 year but this look
nice after takes takes the only chance
is got to not get me to this Queen a
form but I can now play something like
groupie I just have this very active
position with with the pressure and
those pieces don't play yeah this is
very good for black but then he allowed
this chat is made into moose alright
thanks for watching